soyapango en las afueras de San Salvador
vehículos de las fuerzas de seguridad
recorren las calles mientras drones
sobrevuelan la zona miles de soldados y
policías controlan cualquier entrada o
salida del municipio el presidente nayib
bukele ha prometido una guerra sin
cuartel contra las pandillas que asolan
el país
a partir de esos momentos el municipio
de soyapango está totalmente cercado
8500 soldados y 1500 agentes han rodeado
la ciudad mientras los equipos de
extracción de la policía y el ejército
se encargan de sacar uno a uno a todos
los pandilleros que se encuentran ahí
bukele había anunciado que varias
ciudades serían o rodeadas para que la
policía pudiera inspeccionar los hogares
uno por uno y detener a los miembros de
las bandas soyapango es la primera
ciudad donde se utiliza este
procedimiento nosotros
estamos acá para garantizarle la
seguridad a la población honesta
trabajadora a finales de marzo tras la
peor masacre de la historia reciente de
este pequeño país centroamericano
atribuida a las pandillas Y en donde 87
personas murieron en tres días el
gobierno declaró el estado de emergencia
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
denuncian que miles de personas han sido
detenidas a pesar de no tener ninguna
relación con las bandas informan también
de tortura malos tratos y condiciones
inhumanas de encarcelamiento
pese a ello el
75,9% de los salvadoreños apoya el
estado de excepción y el índice de
popularidad de bukele que llevan el
poder desde 2019 ha alcanzado niveles de
récord